[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
laurence à 20 ans je vous remercie
beaucoup d'être avec nous députés la
république en marge du val de marne
rapporteur général de la commission des
finances de l'assemblée nationale
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse quotidienne régionale représentée
par stéphane bern
bonjour et on commence par ces
manifestations hier dans plusieurs
villes de france manifestation contre
les violences policières et ce malgré
les annonces la veille de christophe
castaner le gouvernement n'arrive pas à
calmer la colère
je crois que les annonces du ministre de
l'intérieur ont été clairs et bienvenus
effectivement mais il faut pas tout
confondre dans cette séquence il ya
effectivement une lutte contre le
racisme qui est toujours toujours à sa
lieu pourvu qu'elle soit fait
effectivement par de bonnes intentions
avec de bonnes intentions
et puis il ya cette petite musique sur
les violences policières qui me dérange
un petit peu parce que qu'il y ait
parfois des mauvais comportements dans
la police nationale ou de la gendarmerie
évidemment qu'ils seraient capables de
dire le contraire vous savez il ya des
idiots partout il ya des gens qui disent
des insanités partout et il faut les
sanctionner
plus encore effectivement quand vous
êtes responsable que vous porter
l'uniforme ça là dessus je crois que le
ministre d'intérieur a été très clair il
a eu raison de le dire en même temps il
ya une petite musique moi qui m'inquiète
un petit peu c'est de laisser penser que
la police française est raciste
on a vraiment l'impression que dans ces
manifestations de plus en plus se dit
que la police française est violent et
raciste c'est faux je m'inscris
totalement en faux contre ce discours là
la police française n'est absolument pas
raciste qu'il y ait des dérapages
malheureusement par quelques agents
publics qui doivent être probablement
mieux sanctionner de façon plus
exemplaires oui la police française
n'est pas raciste et je trouve que
l'importation de l'histoire américaine
sur notre sol national est un peu
dangereuse et ça serait à mon avis
manquer de respect et pour l'histoire
américaine et pour l'histoire française
que d'essayer de faire parfois des
parallèles un peu de doute vous êtes en
train de nous dire que le problème c'est
les systèmes de contrôle et de sanction
des policiers qui dérape aujourd'hui
c'est là qu'il ya un souci
il faut quand même savoir que la police
nationale et le corps le plus contrôlé
mais la fonction de la fonction publique
est-ce que la problématique c'est pas dû
confier les enquêtes par exemple à
l'igpn finalement scellé les policiers
qui enquêtent sur les dérapages des
policiers il peut y avoir un débat
là-dessus effectivement est ce qu'à un
moment
doit pas y avoir une part de tutelle par
la justice également pour pour contrôler
et sanctionner
moi je crois aujourd'hui que l'igpn fait
un travail qui est difficile et qui est
assez exemplaire
on ne peut pas reprocher à l'igpn de ne
pas prononcer des sanctions c'est
peut-être pas assez su ça c'est vrai
c'est peut-être passé démontrés et je
vous assure j'étais encore dans le
commissariat de boissy saint léger dans
ma circonscription cette semaine je vous
assure que les policiers sont très
régulièrement contrôlés et surtout
surtout au delà des processus de
contrôle administratif s'il vous plaît
rendez vous bien compte que 99% des
forces de l'ordre de ses agents publics
font ça pour protéger la population et
pour être à leurs côtés
ce ne sont pas des gens qui sont
racistes agressif et violent ne peux pas
laisser dire ça le jour où on perd la
confiance dans notre police et que la
police à linverse perd la confiance
qu'elle peut avoir dans sa population
c'est le chaos il faut absolument
recréer un climat de confiance entre les
forces de l'ordre et la population
heureusement on le voit d'ailleurs dans
les enquêtes d'opinion très très grande
majorité de français a totalement
confiance dans les forces de l'ordre
c'est heureux mais ces manifestations
sont parfois une loupe grossissante
assez erronée de ce que pourraient
penser l'opinion publique
attention la police française n'est pas
raciste n'est pas violente
il ne faut pas laisser dire ce genre de
manifestations auxquelles étaient
présentes des parlementaires malgré
l'interdiction à ces manifestations
étaient interdites pour cause d'état
d'urgence sanitaire qu'est ce que vous
pensez de la présence de ces
parlementaires côté un parlementaire et
libre je suis pas là pour faire la leçon
de morale de savoir où est-ce qui doit
se trouvait où non j'en appelle chacun à
la responsabilité évidemment sur le
respect des conditions sanitaires mais
au delà
j'en appelle aussi à la responsabilité
sur la parole qui est donnée qui est
démontré ce que je disais tout à l'heure
quand on est représentant du peuple
quand on est parlementaire par exemple
on ne peut pas dire que la police est
raciste comme si c'était un
parlementaire qui votent la loi ça ne
nous pose pas problème qui soit une
manifestation interdite
si bien sûr que si ça pose un problème
tout parlementaire qui enfreint la loi
à tort par par définition mais je crois
que au delà du simple du simple non
respect de la règle de sanitaires qui
est déjà une faute en soi vous avez
raison mais il ya aussi le message et la
symbolique et ça ça m'importe
particulièrement c'est à dire que un
parlementaire représente
vous avez dit la nation la loi
la fée il écrit il applique sur le
terrain et donc il a aussi cette co
responsabilité quand il s'adresse à la
police nationale est donc un
parlementaire qui généralisera des
comportements honteux par quelques
individus isolés dans la police
nationale
comme si la police était raciste et
parfois malheureusement il ya une petite
musique de la part de certains bons
d'extrême gauche dans notre dans notre
hémicycle je pense que c'est le député
de certains pour pas tous ceux là aussi
al'inverse ne faisant pas l' amalgame
mais il ya effectivement certains propos
qui parfois dérapent ne sont
probablement pas pensé sont là un petit
peu pour attiser mais je crois qu'à
mettre de l'huile sur ces flammes là sur
ces braises là dans notre pays c'est
extrêmement dangereux et extrêmement
coupable vous évoquiez à l'instant la
confiance comme un point clé la
confiance entre la police et la
population et vice versa est ce que le
chef de l'état peut restaurer cette
confiance est ce qu'il doit prendre la
parole dans cette histoire oui ou non et
pourquoi le chef de l'état prendra la
parole de façon il le fera plus globale
le chef de l'état prendra la parole
c'est pour quand je les passe de façon
plus globale non pas sur les violences
policières et le prochain chef de l'état
s'adressera aux français sur l'état de
la crise sanitaire l'état de la crise
économique l'état de la crise sociale et
l'état de notre pays
l'inconnue sociétale évidemment que ces
sujets là seront abordés d'une manière
ou d'une autre c'est normal à partir du
moment où il ya des choses qui se
passent dans notre pays le chef de
l'état est concerné en premier lieu
c'est normal et donc s'exprimera aussi
sur les sujets démocratiques également
sur les sujets de réconciliation dans
notre pays il y a effectivement vous je
ne m'en cache pas un enjeu pour la fin
du mandat de réconcilier davantage le
pays il y a des fractures
aujourd'hui nous l'avons vu avec les
gilet jaune d'un point de vue social
nous voyons avec les manifestations
aujourd'hui d'un point de vue peut-être
plus territoriales et malheureusement
parfois un peu plus communautaire ce
qu'il faut absolument éviter justement
et notre enjeu une de nos
responsabilités pour la fin de ce mandat
c'est de ne surtout pas laisser
s'aggraver ces fractures
surtout si elles sont communautaires
mais bien de les rassembler et de
rappeler que nous sommes nation et que
nous faisons tous la france et qu'il n'y
a ni différents en français à un autre
en fonction de sa couleur de peau en
fonction de son origine ou en fonction
de sa religion et que surtout la police
par exemple puisqu'on en parle est
d'abord là pour ça
viré pour protéger sa population et pas
pour le presser et l'a sanctionné
allez on va parler d'un autre sujet le
gouvernement qui ne prolongera pas
vraisemblablement l'état d'urgence
sanitaire au delà du 10 juillet mais un
projet de loi est présenté ce matin en
conseil des ministres pour restreindre
les libertés pour une durée de quatre
mois vous n'arrivez pas à sortir de cet
entre deux de ses en même temps
justement c'est une sortie en sifflet
comme on dit d'eux des prérogatives et
des outils qui sont à donner à
l'exécutif c'est une très bonne méthode
l'état d'urgence doit rester une
situation exceptionnelle et de
gouvernement l'a toujours dit et il le
respecte voilà il a été voté deux fois
parce que le confinement l'exigé
considère aujourd'hui que n'ya plus
matière à prolonger l'état d'urgence
fectivement delà du 10 juillet c'est
heureux je pense que c'est une bonne
mesure parce que parfois on peut être un
petit peu trop habituée des mauvais
outil qui serait un peu trop
effectivement à la faveur de l'exécutif
non nous sommes justement est ce qu'avec
ce projet de loi vous ne prêtez pas le
flanc à ceux qui vous disaient que les
mesures de l'état d'urgence vont finir
par entrer dans le droit commun est ce
que là finalement ce n'est pas le cas
pas du tout puisque c'est un projet de
loi qui là encore présentera de façon
temporaire des outils qui permettra à
l'exécutif de garder des capacités à
réagir vite en cas de nouvelle
catastrophe sanitaire c'est plutôt
intelligent je trouve c'est à dire que
l'état d'urgence non c'est terminé ça ne
se justifie plus mais il faut quand même
faire conserver à l'exécutive quelques
outils qui sont très différents de
l'état d'urgence qui lui permettent de
réagir un peu plus vite que justement le
régime de droit commun
et puis quand tout ça sera derrière nous
vraiment derrière nous alors il sera
temps de revenir à notre régime de droit
commun sur la situation de l'hôpital et
de la santé en général vous suivez les
travaux devenus c'est dur de la santé
qu'est ce qui est ce qui se profile
alors d'abord il ya une volonté
politique inouïe inouïe inédite sur le
fait d'investir enfin dans notre hôpital
public à deux volets de la sortie de ce
ségur là c'est effectivement mieux
reconnaître les ce métier-là et mieux
les rémunérer il faut dire les choses
telles qu'elles sont il faut mieux les
gratifier font mieux les payer
et puis il ya le sujet de
l'investissement dans l'hôpital parce
que c'est pas parce qu'on aura mieux
payer le personnel est une partie
importante
c'est pas parce qu'on aura uniquement
mieux payer le personnel que l'hôpital
public sera totalement libéré de ses
difficultés donc il faut leur
les moyens d'investissements et fonds de
ces camps à quelle hauteur ses moyens
vous avez un andré trop tôt pour le dire
et c'est justement pour ça que le
secteur de la santé sert à faire de la
concertation sert d'abord à écouter
évaluer les moyens nécessaires bien sûr
ce que fait nicole notât aux côtés du
ministre de la santé aujourd'hui dans
les territoires c'est précisément mais
vous allez voir échelle ça peut
représenter connaît aujourd'hui nous
avons déjà initié cette dynamique là par
exemple en reprenant un tiers de la
dette des hôpitaux publics tout l'avant
voté en commission
avant-hier dans ce qui s'appelle le
projet de loi organique sur le transfert
de la dette sociale nous avons repris
une partie de la dette des hôpitaux
pourquoi parce que quand vous alléger
l'endettement des hôpitaux vouloir
redonner de l'oxygène du souffle pour
réinvestir donc faire des achats donc
permettre de moderniser l'hôpital la
modernisation de l'hôpital est une des
clés de la réussite de ségur de la santé
mais pour ça il ya deux manières de
faire soit vous faites un plan de août
en bas parce que vous êtes persuadé
d'avoir la vision et puis après on se
rend compte que dans l'application c'est
pas aussi simple que ça et ça va pas
toucher les bonnes personnes
soit vous prenez un peu plus de temps et
c'est tout l'objet du ségur de la santé
et vous écouter vous écouter et vous
concerter d'accord et vous allez
chercher justement des solutions de
compromis vous allez chercher finalement
les solutions qui s'adaptent au mieux à
ce que vous disent les professionnels
faut écouter le terrain aux côtés le
terrain et de ségur de la santé c'est
écouter le terrain hospitaliers et les
mesures seront présentées
ça sera traduit par différentes manières
deux façons soit législatives soient
réglementaires peu importe là le
véhicule on va dire normatif mais ce qui
sera promis à l'issue du c ur de la
santé sera fort voilà sera fort et sera
sans précédent
et je rappelle juste parce que c'est
toujours un petit peu un petit peu
baroque de faire croire qu'on se
réveille avec cette crise sanitaire sur
la question de l'hôpital enfin faut
quand même rappeler que depuis trois ans
on a augmenté les budgets comme personne
ne l'avait fait qu'ils aient toujours
des problématiques de matériel de
logistique rémunération bien sûr et
enfin le budget de l'hôpital ni déjà en
augmentation depuis trois ans tant que
de ségur de la santé sait pas on se
réveille on se rend compte que c'est un
sujet à l'hôpital c'est une accélération
d'un processus qui a déjà commencé quand
agnès buzyn et ministre de la santé et
qu'il nous faut prolonger d'ici la fin
de mandat avec justement à une remise à
plat des besoins avec
une remise à plat des outils possibles
augmentations de salaires des soignants
qui n'étaient pas prévus et
effectivement et une ojeda dennis bien
et une augmentation à des salaires c'est
l'augmentation des salaires
là aussi et qui n'auraient pas eu lieu
s'il n'y avait pas eu cette crise de la
mise en paiement
vous savez l'augmentation des salaires
dans la fonction publique que ce soit
celle d'état salle hospitalière ou celle
de la fonction publique territoriale
c'est toujours très très cher pour la
collectivité parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'agents publics et des personnes qui le
ressentent assez peu sur leur feuille de
paie donc par définition si vous voulez
faire une augmentation massive ce qui
est importante qui doit avoir lieu
ça va vous coûter encore plus cher donc
il faut le faire sur l'endettement
l'endettement votre ya des moments pour
le faire plus ou moins et c'est vrai
qu'une sortie de crise est un moment 1
pour s'endetter pour répondre à la crise
et donc pour mieux rémunérer nos
enseignants qui en plus ont été en
première ligne et le mérite amplement
mais on voulait dire sessegnon qu'est ce
que j'ai dit les incendies anglais
soulignant que jerry tendance ici mais
la commission denquête le le sénat et
l'assemblée nationale qui mette en place
des commissions d'enquêté sur la gestion
de ce que vivent 19 la manière dont le
gouvernement a géré et l'elysée qui
annonce la mise en place de sa propre
commission denquête est ce que pour vous
c'est une atteinte aux droits du
parlement
le parlement a des prérogatives que le
constituant lui a donné qu'
effectivement de contrôler l'action de
l'exécutif dont acte donc c'est au
parlement de se saisir de mon cas cette
commission d'information de commission
denquête qui ont lieu je rappelle que la
mission d'information sur la crise
sanitaire et la crise économique a eu
lieu au parlement depuis le tout début
richard ferrand a mis ça en place dans
les tout premiers jours j'en suis un des
membres et elle s'est transformée en
commission denquête le rapporteur de
cette commission denquête n'est pas
franchement un farouche partisan de la
majorité ce monsieur eric ciotti pas
dire qu'on respecte pas les droits de
l'opposition on le fait dans justement
une logique transpartisane parce qu'une
commission denquête doit faire cette cet
effort de de valade non seulement de
transparence mais aussi de respect des
oppositions donc on donne la main même
le rapport on le donne à eric ciotti et
à l'opposition donc je pense que ça
c'est important
le sénat doit faire également son
travail là tu pourquoi est-ce-que
l'exécutif fait aussi ce travail là
c'est pas la même logique n'est pas là
pour se contrôler lui-même il est là
pour mieux comprendre pour mieux
comprendre ce qui a pu dysfonctionné
également son sein mais ça n'a pas
constitutionnellement c'est l'objectif
premier des commission denquête monté
par le sénat et l'assemblée la de mieux
comprendre ce qui s'est passé la valeur
constitutionnelle d'une commission
d'enquêté parlementaire et la plus
importante
évidemment qu'il y ait des travaux au
sein de l'elysée au sein du gouvernement
pour mieux comprendre certains
dysfonctionnements internes et ça ne
saurais pas dire le contraire les
conditions d' enquête parlementaire vous
êtes en train de dire quelle prime sur
ce que pourrait monter le non seulement
l'elysée constitue chez l'annonceur et
six revers de la république de paris qui
ouvre rue ou qui ouvre une enquête en
fait ça est ce que c'est pas de nature à
à perturber ou ou limiter la portée
d'action des commissions d enquête
parlementaire
à écouter c'est à chacun de respecter la
constitution dans laquelle nous vivons
mais justement je fonce les risques au
point pour le coup le parlement est
l'organe qui a légitimité pour contrôler
l'exécutif
voilà et les conditionnent enquêtes sont
en cours et nous verrons bien les
conclusions qui seront menées mais je
n'ai aucun doute sur le fait que le
parlement peut pas enquêter sur des sur
des sur des sur des procédures
judiciaires en cours donc du coup votre
votre marge de manoeuvre de votre rayon
d'action ne sera-t-il pas limité par set
cette initiative judiciaire je fais
toute confiance rapporteur à la
commission d enquête et à l'ensemble des
membres pour trouver toutes les marges
de manoeuvre que la constitution leur
leur procure pour aller effectivement
poser les bonnes questions auditionner
les bons les bons responsables et
surtout c'est ça qui m'importe moi vous
savez la question n'est pas de savoir
qui a la meilleure commission denquête
surtout est-ce qu'on ressort de cette
crise avec des outils améliorés
modernisée qui nous permettent de mieux
anticiper les crises quand demain elle
venait à se reproduire
un dernier mot là dessus il ya une
soixantaine de plaintes qui ont été
déposées contre des membres du
gouvernement sur cette gestion de la
crise est ce que vous les comprenez ces
plaintes il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
bruit politique derrière ces plaintes il
faut pas être naïf il ya beaucoup de
militantisme je trouve un peu indécent
entre nous que puisse avoir des plaintes
au milieu de la crise qu'on voit comment
le gouvernement a pu gérer de façon
assez exemplaire cette crise sanitaire
le reste maintenant c'est à la justice
de s'en saisir ce n'est pas à moi
d'interférer bien sûr mais je trouve que
parfois certains militantisme un peu un
peu désoeuvrés pendant cette crise
aurait mieux fait de participer à cette
union nationale équipe et je suis pas
politique je suis pas là linverse pour
porter des plaintes dans l'autre sens
moi je me préoccupe du pays et comment
est-ce qu'on peut effectivement avancer
tous ensemble
je trouve juste que certains n'ont pas
fait grand chose et se sont contentés de
porter plainte le troisième budget
rectificatif va être présenté ce matin
en conseil des ministres et un budget de
plus de 40 milliards en soutien
notamment aux secteurs en difficulté
l'aéronautique l'automobile le tourisme
est ce que vous savez ce qui contient
plus précisément c'est un budget
rectificatif d'abord qui va redéfinir
une nouvelle trajectoire de finances
publiques parce que tous les mois elle
évolue malheureusement nous avons une
récession qui va être estimée à 11
points c'est quand même beaucoup
nous avons un déficit qu'il a dépassé
les 10% nous d'avoir un endettement on
sait gaza ce sont ce sont des chiffres
qui donnent un petit peu le vertige pour
en porter le budget que je suis mais il
faut les assumer faut les prendre comme
tel et la crise est très violente et
maintenant l'objectif c'est comment
est-ce qu'on permet à nos secteurs
économiques à nous ont pas de rebondir
comme on dit dans le jargon à économie
donc effectivement c'est un texte il va
prolonger l'urgence économique le fonds
de solidarité
l'activité partielle pour certains
certains cas le prêt garanti par l'état
en continu toutes ces mesures d'urgence
économique
et puis cette fois si dans ce texte on
commence à cibler par secteur ce qui en
ont le plus besoin vous en avez cité
certains l'automobile l'aéronautique le
tourisme et la restauration la presse le
collectif droit territorial et j'allais
venir
un troisième volet important qui est
l'aide importante aux collectivités
territoriales elles y ont participé
par leurs baisses de recettes fiscales
notamment à la crise et puis qui ont
fait aussi des dépenses de
fonctionnement tant qu'il était
important dans un pays où il ya de
l'autonomie financière des collectivités
mais pas de l'autonomie fiscale il est
important que l'état prenne le relais et
soutiennent les collectivités le premier
ministre là dessus a été sans ambiguïté
l'état viendra compenser et aider les
collectivités locales à hauteur
dit de façon vertigineuse je reprends un
terme que l'usagé 460 milliards de soude
d'euros de soutien public du fait de ces
trois projets de loi de finances
rectificative cumulés c'est juste
énormissime comment on va trouver cet
argent ou est-ce qu'on va le chercher
vous évoquiez le l'emprunt tout à
l'heure en dix ans et les périodes de
crise et moment d'emprunter mais quand
même on est sur des montants
hallucinants c'est du jamais vu
c'est du jamais vu 20% à payer 20% du
produit intérieur brut consacré à la
crise
c'est du jamais vu comment on va payer
nous avons fait le choix de nous
endetter
endetter vous savez c'est possible de la
durée sans augmenter les impôts vous
répondre mais d'abord il faut que les
français comprennent qu'il n'ya pas 36
solutions pour trouver de l'argent soit
dans le prélève s'appelle l'impôt soit
on emprunte sur les marchés où sont en
fait des économies hier il n'était ni
raisonnable de demander aux français de
participer à hauteur du montant que vous
avez cités étaient ni raisonnable
d'aller faire des économies de
fonctionnement hauteur de 400 milliards
d'euros
donc nous avons choisi l'endettement qui
était la meilleure des solutions il se
trouve que nous sommes dans un contexte
macro économique avec des taux d'intérêt
très bas
il se trouve que nous pouvons emprunter
à 10 ans à taux zéro il aurait été
coupable de ne pas profiter cette
situation où les marchés sont favorables
et il se trouve que la france est quoi
qu'on en dise dans notre pays souvent
pessimiste une excellente référence sur
les marchés financiers la france avec
les etats-unis et l'allemagne est la
meilleure signature comme on dit sur les
marchés financiers c'est à dire que l'on
veut nous prêter plus que ce que nous
émettons nous n'allons quand même pas
nous priver de ce privilège et nous
avons la capacité aujourd'hui à financer
la crise est-ce que ça doit durer
éternellement et qui va rembourser à la
fin cette dette est ce que ça doit durer
éternellement non bien sûr nous devons
nous endetter autant que de besoin
guère plus parce que sinon justement ce
qui nous prête un moment ne vaut plus
vouloir donc prêté donc il faut être
responsable il faut être sérieux
budgétairement mais ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il ne faut pas avoir recours à
l'endettement
et qui paiera un jour vous savez la
dette publique c'est pas votre dette
avec votre ménage quand vous achetez
votre crédit immobilier
ce n'est pas non plus la dette de la pme
qui doit rembourser chaque mois à la
banque ça fonctionne pas comme ça une
dette souveraine une dette souveraine se
refinancent
ça veut pas dire que ça se rembourse pas
mais ça se refinancent est ce qui compte
surtout budgétairement
c'est à dire pour les citoyens et pour
leurs impôts c'est la charge de la dette
le coût de la dette
à partir du moment où vous avez une
charge de la dette qui est si basse vous
pouvez augmenter votre capital qui sera
renouvelée par de nouvelles émissions
et puis effectivement quand la crise est
passé quand les nuages sont un petit peu
partie vous devez effectivement
stabiliser votre dette et commencer à la
réduire
effectivement aujourd'hui la france a
une capacité d'endettement qui est
encore tout à fait possible et qui est
encore tout à fait acceptée par ceux qui
nous prêtent c'est ça qui est rassurant
c'est ça que la crise aussi nous a
démontré parce que vous savez vous ne le
savez pas tant que vous êtes affronter
directement par cette crise face à vos
créanciers il se trouve qu'il ya même
plus de demandes parce que le produit
que l'on met sur le marché notre dette
notre dette à tous elle est demandée
mais nous devons nous devons absolument
utiliser sont garantis que à court terme
ou à moyen terme il y aura aucune
augmentation d'impôts ou de création
bulgare ans un pot pour rembourser
j'aurais pu voir dans les yeux il n'y a
pas on ne touche pas aux impôts je vous
le garantis il n'y aura pas
d'augmentation prélèvements obligatoires
sous ce quinquennat c'est la seule
garantie que je vais vous donner parce
qu'après je ne sais pas si je serai
responsabilités pour vous le garantir à
nouveau et d'ici fin 2022 il y en aura
pas n'y en aura pas pour deux raisons
d'abord parce que ce serait idiot de
croire qu'on remboursera et les déficits
à 11,4 avec delà de l'augmentation
d'impôts en deux ans c'est faux les
échelles sont totalement différentes
donc nous ne pouvons pas de toute façon
réduire des visites aussi rapidement ça
prendra des années donc ça ne se réglera
pas par deux ans d'impôts et
deuxièmement c'est totalement contre
productif en demande aux français de
consommer plus parce que ils ont de
l'épargné excédentaire liés au
confinement en demande aux entreprises
de redémarrer d'investir 1 quand même
pas les sabres et avec des prélèvements
obligatoires et un moment il faut un peu
de cohérence économique la relance passe
par au contraire une capacité avoir de
l'oxygène une capacité à pouvoir soit
consommé comme vous êtes aux ménages
soit investir quand vous êtes une
entreprise toc oui je vous le répète pas
d'augmentation d'impôts pendant dernière
question stéphane comment quelle est
l'ambiance au sein de l héroïne
la république en marche comment ça se
passe il ya une réunion groupe pierre
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en donner
quelques éléments d'ambiance
je ne vous donnerai aucun élément parce
que même si tous fuites n'ont justement
pas j'ai une doctrine très pénible un
peu vieux jeu vous me l'accorderez mais
ce qui reste dans une réunion privée n'a
pas à sortir publiquement donc je vais
écouter aujourd'hui le groupe la
république en marche et concentré mais
réellement concentré et j'en suis la
preuve vivante
aujourd'hui je vais recevoir les
ministres à la commission des finances
il est constant ont préparé franchement
il ya quand même quelques lignes de
fracture
je comprends je comprends c'est un
reproche l'appétence pour le potin
politiques liées au groupe lions
franchement si vous avez un groupe
majoritaire à l'assemblée est ce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un groupe affaibli
contre un président affaibli à sa tête
on contre on n'est pas affaibli quand on
est en responsabilité qu'on traverse la
plus violente crise que le pays n'a
jamais connu les français s'en fichent
pas mal de savoir qui est à la tête du
groupe la république en marque
est-ce qu'il est fragilisé est-ce qu'il
envoyait une autre cas fuite etc je vous
assure je vous assure que les français
s'en fichent pas mal et ils ont raison
traverse une crise au réseau pas le
moment vers d'autres visées mais le
groupe est là en plus de groupes quand
même
le groupe est là il est présidé par le
tempo et pas formidable le groupe est là
il un président nous sommes à la tâche
nous avons un projet de l'authie danse
rectificative a voté nous le ferons nous
le ferons et nous préparons les deux
prochaines années avec une nouvelle
stratégie très probablement qui sera
d'abord présentée par le président de la
république dans quelques semaines et
nous faisons les choses par étapes
vraiment je suis plus que jamais et je
crois que nous ne sommes collectivement
concentrer sur le fait de transformer ce
pays et de l'aider à sortir de la crise
tout le reste c'est de la littérature
politicienne qui n'est absolument pas
prioritaire